Max export from China over €500 billion.
Export from European Union to China €230 billion in the same time.
Madam President, you are forcing European citizens with the green deal.
When Europe is responsible for 7% of pollution of the globe.
And you want to save Europe with our pockets?
This is madness. And this madness will be stopped after this elections.
We gonna make Europe great again.
We gonna change the numbers.
And your life will not change
the fact that you are going to lose this elections.
You know that. And you know that,
Madam President. You know why?
Because there is no freedoms you mention.
We can read in the conclusions that you know
must be safe for European citizens.
It's your fault, Madam President,
that it's not safe illegal migration.
And your policy, Mister Weber,
German policy real common is. It's.
It's the. It's the reason why Europe is not safe.
Let's talk about the reports about Germany.
Safety in Germany. 6 million crimes raised.
The highest rise in the history of Germany.
And you wanna continue that?
This madness about league
illegal migration will be stopped after this election.
This madness about the Green Deal,
Madam President, will be stopped about this madness.
And your smiles and good humor will not change the fact
that conservatives will make Europe great again.
Thank you.